all right dan yes dan where'd you grow
where are you from originally i grew up
in clark new jersey union county new
jersey lifelong resident and tell me
about your family you had mom and dad
growing up yeah you know i grew up
mostly with my dad my mom left when i
was really young i was the second born
and my mom left i think around two years
old i was about two and she was out of
my life for a good number of years
dealing with some stuff emotional issues
and my dad raised my brother and myself
so three guys in the house how would you
describe your childhood
um
very rigid
uh my father was of german descent and
so everything was a rule everything was
very straightforward and strict not a
lot of emotion but you know good student
loved playing sports but i was
definitely lived in fear of of my dad no
doubt
okay what can i give you in high school
i was i was a good student i went to
church every sunday uh played sports i
loved playing sports played baseball
but i also had this other side of me and
this other side of me that kind of loved
the world of gambling something i got
introduced to through my dad and through
just growing up in the house so i was
kind of a jekyll and hyde if you will
so you're a good athlete yes like a
gambler at the same time yeah and the
gambling's easy to hide you know
gambling's one of those hidden
addictions that if somebody doesn't know
you they can't test for it you're not
gonna p dice there's no urine screen for
it but it was easy to hide so you know
the one side of me would play sports go
to church good student you know b plus a
minus but then the other side of me was
marking cards playing poker with my
friends on friday or saturday night and
i was basically stealing money from them
because i i was marking the cards and so
there was this this evil side or this
dark side that kind of lurked beneath
the surface and when did that kind of
start showing its head i would say in
high school you know i grew up going to
the racetrack in north jersey and i
loved it i loved the feeling of
handicapping horses and all that and so
the friends i made in high school
basically centered around gambling i
made friends with a kid whose father was
a bookmaker a bookie in new jersey
illegally and we would go to atlantic
city we enjoyed all the fine things the
sweets and all the foods and all that
but then it started i started running
poker games at the local library right
next to the police station never got
caught uh started running card games and
i just started betting on sports started
handicapping started taking people's
money so it started really early but
never at a high level it was just always
kind of bubbling below the surface but
it was something i definitely enjoyed
doing it wasn't a problem
it got to be a problem my senior year of
high school
uh senior year of high school i had bet
about a thousand dollars on five
football games and i lost every game i
went 0-5 and my dad found the betting
slips and he said are these your betting
slips did you actually gamble on these
games and i said yes i did and he said
you've got a problem he goes let me know
when you're fixed
and that always i think back to that now
like let me know when you're fixed for
people who struggle with addiction it's
not a matter of being broken or need to
be fixed right and uh that was the first
sign where i thought okay maybe i do
have a problem so i went to see a
counselor and the counselor said you
don't have a gambling problem you're mad
at your mom for leaving you when you
were young so they kind of dismissed the
gambling addiction and they focused on
my relationship with my mom so i kind of
skated by on that one it really never
talked about it but it was always
bubbling below the surface do you think
losing not not having your mom in your
life early on was a big big part of it
you know looking backwards now that i
understand the importance of childhood
experiences i would say yes that
contributed to it but i think it was
also the early exposure you know like
the meadowlands racetrack is where i
felt i bonded with my father he worked
hard and he's from german descent so
there's not a lot of i love use or hugs
but at the racetrack i get to see a
different side of him i got to see him
smile we would high five we would spend
time together and for a young person
who's exposed to that and they see
gambling is at the center i think that's
where i kind of tucked it away and said
wow gambling is that thing that brings
families together it bonds you with your
dad 100 and that's what i wanted you
know i'm a young person i'm like i'm 12
years old when i first went to the
racetrack with my dad i wasn't placing
bets but i spent time with him and i
loved going there because i just loved
that time we could spend together so
definitely i think i saw it early on as
a positive yeah
and then after school you got jobs yeah
so i uh in junior year of my high school
before senior year i was actually
pitching i was a baseball player i was
scattered by the phillies and the reds
two major league teams as well as three
colleges
tennessee and knoxville east carolina
and nc state
and baseball was great and i had some
great advice from some of the scouts but
i didn't want to listen to them they
gave me a good piece of advice to fix my
mechanics or else i was going to have a
rotator cuff injury and i was a 17 year
old
big ego teenager and i said i'm fine i
haven't had an injury yet i'm good and
six months later i developed an arm
problem and my rotator cuff i started
having strains ended up with a partial
tear ended up losing all those great
opportunities
played division three baseball for about
a month at the college of new jersey and
then after a month my arm gave out and
my career was done i ended up graduating
with a major in finance and a minor in
economics and i got my first job over
here in new york city at a tiny little
investment bank named goldman sachs
and you were working there
for how long yeah i graduated 1998 so
i'm 46 now i graduated 1998 and i was
there for five years but during that
five year period
things were going really well i was
involved in a really fast lifestyle the
things that i was really comfortable
with as someone who liked to gamble i
love risk taking i love being a part of
a really high action high intense
environment and that certainly did the
job but i was also downtown on september
11th when the towers were struck and i
remember that day like it was yesterday
you know i remember the night before on
september 10th it was a rainy night in
new york city i was supposed to go to
the yankee game and it got rained out i
went home that night watched tv went to
bed woke up the next day it was a
beautiful tuesday morning on september
11th and i remember going
across the uh the river through the path
station i got into the towers around 6
15 in the morning when i always got into
the uh trade center i walked out of the
trade center towards my office about a
quarter mile to the east i went to the
gym like i did most mornings and i was
up in my office around eight in the
morning
about an hour later everything changed
i remember sitting in my office and i
saw a plane flying really low on the
horizon and i thought that was kind of
odd
and as i'm watching the plane fly low it
kind of disappeared out of my view and
the next thing i remember was just
seeing a plume of smoke and i just
couldn't wrap my head around what was
happening
and i would say the next hour was a blur
i don't remember a lot of the details of
the next hour just a lot of mayhem and
and phone calls and then the phone shut
off and they wouldn't dial out and
people running through the office and i
remember my managing director running
into my office saying we have to go we
have to go now and i remember following
him down the stairs not knowing where we
were going thinking we were going to try
to leave the city instead we ended up
running towards the towers
and i always say there's certain
elements of life i wish i could unsee
i remember um going towards the towers
and i remember from about 25 30 feet
away seeing a flash and i saw a body hit
the pavement
i remember seeing another body hit the
pavement people started jumping out of
windows because they felt that was a
better alternative
to what they were seeing inside
my managing director ended up losing his
wife that day i ended up losing 14
friends
as i would find out in the days and
weeks that followed
um
that was hard
i still to this day get chills talking
about it you know
trauma lives in the body and when you
talk about things it's um
it's hard
and i remember that next day i remember
i finally made it home that day after
september 11th and i cried and cried and
had no more tears left
i remember on september 12th though the
next day after september 11th i didn't
know what to do with myself i've always
been very motivated very driven type a
a self-starter and for that first time
in my life i didn't know what to do
and i remember coming down to my living
room i was living in northern new jersey
at the time
married only a matter of a few months
and i remember opening up online account
putting hundred dollars
into an offshore gambling site called
bowdog at the time and i remember
playing blackjack for about 45 minutes
that's all 45 minutes just to start the
day
closed the laptop down and then went
about my day i went to sit on a rock so
i could see the smoke coming up from
downtown new york
and i did that
every day for the next several weeks and
all of a sudden gambling started to
become that thing that i did every
morning to start my day for the next
eight and a half years
gambling was the thing that i used to
escape
september 11th
interesting probably the stress of it
all ptsd
yeah it was
yeah i i had such a fond direct i always
knew gambling like was something that i
tucked away as being a good experience
so when i didn't know what to do
in my life at that moment
i didn't know how to
share my emotions i grew up in a house
where i didn't share emotions i grew up
in a house where it was all about the
rules not about the relationships
i grew up in a house where we didn't say
i love you and feel free to cry
it was keep it all in and just keep
moving forward and work harder
and so for me i didn't know what my
outlet looked like i didn't have
experience with that but for me gambling
was that thing that made me forget about
life for a while just like people use
drugs or alcohol for me it was gambling
as an athlete someone who played sports
at a high level someone who then started
to dive into the world of triathlon swim
bike and run i didn't want to take
things in my body that might alter my
sports performance gambling was the
thing i could find that didn't give me a
hangover nobody could tell i didn't have
track marks i didn't have any kind of
visible impairment and it was something
i could do secretly so i can continue to
keep this image up of the successful
you know
hard-working individual
who was not impacted by september 11th
nobody wanted to hear my problems i was
alive i had survivors guilt i would come
to find out i had ptsd i never talked to
anyone about this i didn't talk to
anyone about my problems in 2001 we
didn't talk about mental health like we
do today
today it's okay to not be okay and it's
okay to talk about it back then i had to
put that mask on and i wore that mask
every day and i used gambling to help me
cope
and like i said it started off playing
blackjack but then it progresses like
all addictions do gambling is no
different the only difference with
gambling is that i didn't put it in my
body it didn't go in my bloodstream i
didn't consume it it impacted my brain
though because i needed to gamble for
longer periods of time for increasing
amounts of money and for more days
during the week blackjack become became
blackjack and poker it included sports
betting all of a sudden i was just
gambling on various things every day
every chance i could and when i wasn't
gambling i was always thinking about
when the next time i could gamble would
be
i lasted in the city another two years
from 2001 after september 11 until 2003
i spent another two years at goldman
sachs loved my work but the stress was
weighing on me i remember our new
building when we moved back into the
city and the new location
was right near a helicopter landing pad
and every time i would hear that
helicopter come in for a landing my
heart rate would spike i would get
lightheaded and i thought i'd faint
because i was having those symptoms of
ptsd from september 11th i ended up
leaving goldman in 2003 to become a
financial planner with prudential in new
jersey i couldn't work in the city
anymore was was handling other people's
money a problem yeah and and i would
find that out as the years rolled by as
i was slowly starting to develop this
this addiction to gambling you know it
became a problem and it gradually became
a habit and in forming into an addiction
where i needed to just do this thing
every day just to feel better and that's
how you know that's how i knew i started
running into a problem but i didn't know
what to do about it
what's remarkable about gambling is that
every so often you actually win
and when you win it feels really damn
good
and it's hard to give something up that
you know you're gonna win but the
problem is i didn't know how much i
would win how often it would happen or
when it would happen next and that was
the hook that kept me coming back to it
every day
and so over time i slowly ran through
all of my savings and resources all the
restricted stock i had received from
goldman i was at goldman when they went
public i had a tremendous amount of
stock awards i went through all of my
401k started going through all the
savings
in june of 2008
i
committed my first
illegal act
and i was in charge of other people's
money as a financial planner i had a
great book of clients a lot of people
that trusted me and i remember i
received a phone call from a client who
had a family friend who had just
received an inheritance from their uncle
and she needed some guidance on how to
manage those funds
i went to the house fully anticipating
just to
present a few options
and then just leave because i'm not a
high pressure person here's here's what
i would recommend let me know i'll
follow up in a week that's how i always
did all of my appointments but on this
particular occasion she said no i want
to i want to sign up right now i want
this particular investment product who
do i make the check payable to
and in a split second i did not go into
the house in intending to do this but
when she said who do i make the check
payable to
i had just lost eight thousand dollars
before this appointment gambling online
i had someone who was going to invest
ten thousand dollars with me that could
pay off my eight thousand dollar
loss
so in a blink of an eye i told her you
make the pay check payable to dan to dan
trollero my name
and she did
no questions asked she wrote a check
payable to 10 for 10 000 payable to me i
took that check i put it in my bank
account
i remember driving home at that moment
saying
it just changed
i just crossed that line i crossed i
can't go back i just crossed that line i
can't i can't now admit what i just did
because i'll be in trouble i don't want
to be in trouble i'll figure this
gambling thing out it'll be okay i'll
repay her the money and no one will ever
know that's how it started in my mind i
called it a loan
in the next three days i turned that ten
thousand dollars into zero i lost her
ten thousand dollars
i now owed her 10 000
and i had no money to gamble with my
credit cards were maxed out and i didn't
know what to do next
so i did what i thought was the next
logical thing and what people in active
addiction do
is they look for the way out
and my way out was to make another
appointment with another
one of my customers who i know was very
busy with life
that didn't pay close attention to their
accounts
and i made a recommendation
and i started this process for the next
20 months of making appointments
stealing checks defrauding over 12 of my
customers over 20 months for over 2.1
million dollars
to fuel an ever-growing online gambling
addiction
i remember when um when i was caught and
a few months before that
the way i was caught was november of
2009.
i had uh made an appointment with a
client
had stolen a check from them
deposited the check into my bank account
in northern new jersey
and there was a new bank teller working
that day
and the individual she just simply
deposited it twice into my account a
very innocent mistake she hit the button
or she did whatever she did
so they had to reverse the transaction
and they had to then put it back in the
right way
but because of the magnitude and the
size of the check it was a quarter
million dollar check
it flagged made a red flag to the back
office
and so they started investigating and
researching and what i came to learn
was that that launched a bit of an
investigation into all of my checks and
dealings with customers and with
prudential that led to a three-month
investigation which came to a head on
february 11th of 2010 which is also the
day of my last bet february 11 2010.
and i remember receiving a phone call
from my managing director and he said
dan i think we have a problem
i said what's the problem bob
he said
the prudential home office
would like to talk to you about a
hundred thousand dollar check and some
other checks that you're signing from
clients why are clients
giving you checks and i said i don't
know what you're talking about
i knew exactly what he was talking about
he said i think you better come down
here at four o'clock there's some people
that want to talk to you including the
fbi
i said i can't make it today at four
o'clock he said if you're not here at
four we'll be to your house at 4 30. he
goes i recommend you come here i don't
think you want to make a scene
and he was right i didn't want to make a
scene
you know at that time i have young kids
at that time everyone's in the dark
i'm in good standing in my community
because nobody can tell if someone has a
hidden gambling addiction oftentimes
until it's really late
and i went down to that office
on february 11 2010
and for the next five hours i sat in a
room and i admitted to everything i had
done
they had done their research they had a
stack of papers that were about three
inches thick they knew everything i had
done and i admitted and confessed to
each one each one uh they even forgot a
victim that i even brought up i just i
needed to clear the slate there was a
point that felt really good it felt so
good to get this weight off my shoulders
but it was also really scary and i knew
it would be tremendously hard for
my family my grandparents i was married
at the time my wife at the time my mom
you know everyone
you know
it was such a confusing element like it
feels so good to get this weight off
your shoulders finally to be able to
breathe
but now it's like the unknown
you know with gambling every day i knew
what i was going to get
i knew every day i was going to wake up
and gamble and there was some comfort in
that and i knew i was going to gamble
until my last dollar was gone and there
was a sense of relief when that happened
as a person with a gambling problem
whenever i had money in my account i was
always thinking about what would i
gamble on what would i bet on next and
it was this constant preoccupation i
couldn't be a good father i couldn't be
a good husband i couldn't be a good
community member i couldn't be a good
friend i just wanted to gamble and think
about gambling every waking hour
but when that last dollar was gone there
was a sense of relief and this was that
similar sense of relief all the garbage
is now out there
for the next 18 months
the wheels of justice turn very slowly
from february 11th of 2010 until august
19 of 2011 i waited 18 months before i
was sentenced to six years state prison
i admitted to everything i had done um
prudential made all of the victims whole
and that helped tremendously in my case
prudential repaid all of the victims of
my criminal activity and i'm very
thankful for that
none of those people deserved any of
what i had done you know they came
across me at a time in my life when
i was going through terrible addiction i
never
i should have addressed it i should have
addressed september 11th there's just so
many layers to it looking backwards now
that can't be fixed but i'm thankful
that prudential reimbursed them
i remember getting sentenced on august
19 2011. you know i remember some of the
hardest days of my life was going
through september 11th
and then at the time telling my
twins i had boy girl twins
telling them when they were
six years old
that daddy was going on a business trip
and i didn't know when i'd be back
that was hard
i was thankful that i wasn't gone for
the full six years
between um incarceration being away i
was at a work camp i was on a supervised
release program i was on parole
probation for about four and a half
years total in the system
i remember getting out and kind of
getting off the program completely in
2000 i guess that'd be
2015 2016 time frame
it felt so good to be free again no
restrictions you know i had taken that
time to work on myself i knew i couldn't
gamble i know i don't have a healthy
relationship with gambling if if if i
want to be a good person and a good
human being i know i can't gamble
it doesn't work in my life i don't know
what moderation is i don't understand
how to i don't even want to be a part of
gambling but i want to be a part of the
solution and i want to be a part of
helping people who struggle with life
people who struggle with drugs alcohol
gambling
stress whatever it is i knew i like
people i like working with people i like
talking with people i like relating to
people and having prison experience and
being someone a person with an addiction
because i'm a person first that's the
one thing i always remind people that i
talk to we are people first we're a
person with an addiction
and when we talk to people in recovery
when we talk to the family members
love the person but you don't love their
behavior and that is something i echo
all the time for anyone who struggles
with addiction we love the person but we
don't love that behavior and then we
have to separate the two i knew when i
came out i wanted to help people who
might struggle with gambling and so uh
coming out of prison was was hard
because the first job i had was working
at a little mom-and-pop barbecue
restaurant in northern new jersey making
five dollars an hour serving pork
sandwiches barbecue pork sandwiches and
i remember
going to work in the morning my youngest
daughter at the time
would see me put on my gray shirt with a
little picture of a pig
and it said you know something like we
make pigs fly whatever it was something
silly and she would always say daddy you
going to work at the piggy place that's
what she would always say and it was
humbling yet it was just a reminder of
where i was and i said yep going to work
i'll be home later i didn't get upset i
didn't get upset there's no time for
that
and so i would just do what i had to do
and then i i started moving through and
i was blessed with an opportunity to
speak to a couple of groups who were um
gamblers anonymous fellowship i joined
that uh speaking some outpatient groups
just kind of start giving back
volunteering my time
and then as gambling expanded in new
jersey in 2013 through 2018 internet
gambling sports betting
i was blessed with an opportunity to
work for a non-profit to help educate
and reduce the risk of gambling harm in
the state of new jersey
and i ended up becoming the assistant
executive director over the last several
years there
before leaving for a new opportunity
that was one year ago where i joined
epic risk management as the head of
prevention in the united states
working primarily with the ncaa and
college student athletes to reduce
gambling harm gambling is growing and i
want to be a part of the solution so
that other people don't feel that they
have to hide or don't feel that they
don't have someone to talk to so we go
around to different colleges all around
the country engaging student athletes
sharing my lived experience and my story
in hopes that it resonates and might
make a difference in someone's life it's
nice to hear that you've
taken like 100 responsibility for for
what you did
yeah i can i can easily look backwards
and say oh if you know it's my dad's
fault or it's my mom's fault for leaving
or whatever it might be but that's not
the case you know we have the power to
make choices
in the midst of an addiction when i was
going through the deepest throws of
addiction yeah my brain was hijacked in
the midst of that but i have choices i
take ownership there was a lot of things
that i could have done differently
when i look backwards and he can't fix
the past but when i look backwards i
immediately should have taken advantage
of services and any resources that were
available for people who were downtown
on september 11th i chose not to
and some of that is a function of your
upbringing and your culture right how do
i know how to share my feelings if i've
never modeled i've never seen it modeled
i didn't see my parents married i never
saw
arguments i never saw a conversation and
communicate i didn't know how that stuff
worked so there's a part of they'll say
if i'm never taught how to do something
or if i don't develop a life skill how
do i then go ahead and develop that and
i pushed people away you know there was
a lot where i wanted to live this jekyll
and hyde life
i had this ego i had this competitive
spirit i wanted to do everything bigger
than everyone else i mean that's part of
my personality trait in the midst of my
gambling i had to have if my friends had
bet a hundred dollars i had to bet 500.
if they ordered one dinner i had to
order two i mean i always had to one-up
somebody else
and you look at some of the personality
traits for people who struggle with
addiction specific to gambling and it's
that competitive drive it's that fear of
failure it's that that risk-taking
mentality all of which has just been a
part of my life it's part of my dna and
that's why addiction is so complex it's
biology it's genetics it's who you grew
up around who you make friends with
but i do take ownership i take ownership
because i need to do that for myself so
that i can forgive myself as well in
that i'm not a i'm a flawed human being
you know i'm going to make mistakes
every day
i hurt people along the way
i asked forgiveness from a lot of people
some of which
i didn't get but that's out of my
control and i think about that serenity
prayer all the time of kind of
separating you know knowing what we can
control and knowing what's out of our
control you know having that wisdom to
know the difference between the two
but i had to take ownership i mean it
starts with taking ownership and
accepting accountability and
responsibility and then finding a sense
of usefulness and purpose in my life
which was lacking for so long i had so
much shame and so much guilt until i was
able to start talking about it it
started freeing me from that that mental
prison that i was struggling in
yeah gambling is a
an interesting
addiction i i went to a couple gambling
anonymous gambling anonymous meetings in
vegas when i was there once looking for
gamblers to interview and is very
difficult because they don't want to
talk typically but yeah one of the
things i heard in the meetings over and
over again was
from the gamblers is i have an off
switch but i don't have enough i have an
on switch but i don't have an off switch
yeah
you know it's funny i often hear people
talk about that i've even heard renowned
doctors talk about that once the
addiction switches on it stays on and
and that's that's across the board for
all addictions you know what's
interesting with gambling is what i
mentioned before is the fact that it's
hard to
stop an activity where you're getting
rewarded every so often and if you look
the brain of a gambling a person with a
gambling problem lights up in a similar
regions as someone who has cocaine
addiction the similar areas are
activated and so all of a sudden i'm not
putting anything in my body yet i'm
getting such a buzz and such a high off
this this behavioral process so it
impacts the brain and it's not just the
winning because gambling a lot of people
think gambling is a money problem
gambling's an emotional problem gambling
people with gambling problems are either
using it for action or escape you know i
started as an action gambler i love the
rush but after september 11th i became
an escaped gambler because i didn't know
how to deal with lice is it the
adrenaline of the risk
yeah there's a couple of things it's the
dopamine boost that you keep getting and
that adrenaline it's the anticipation as
well as the participation so it's
thinking about what the next bet will be
thinking about what the outcome will be
and also then actively watching it take
place
so if you're
wagering on the internet or betting on
sports nowadays you can bet on sports
you can put a new bet every 20 seconds
you can bet on the next uh serve in a
tennis match the next pitch in a
baseball game so to to like get that
granular with it i'm anticipating what
it will be i'm hoping for a good outcome
if it happens great it registers and i
move on to the next one but if it
doesn't
i'm still buzzing i'm still feeling
really high and i'm just going to move
on to the next one anyway so either way
i'm getting an adrenaline rush and a
dopamine hit because you work in
prevention or
recovery of gambling i mean what what
kind of numbers do you know about how
common it is so the the
here's a couple of issues in the united
states with gambling is that there's no
federal funding to support treatment
or prevention we have
funding for drug and alcohol prevention
and treatment and services there's no
federal funding for gambling it's all
done at the state level so the research
is limited but the last research the
latest research estimates that roughly
two percent of americans have a
full-blown gambling disorder
now from a percentage perspective that's
not a lot but if you think about how
many people in the united states three
billion people in the united states
two percent with that six hundred
thousand people or something like that
i think the numbers are growing oh
actually no would be higher than that be
like six million six million people six
million six million so the numbers are
growing though and here's where we're
starting to see concern since 2018
sports betting is now starting to become
legalized state by state passport was
repealed that allowed each state to
decide how and if they want to enforce
regulate and and
govern sports betting within its own
state borders new jersey was one of the
first ones to market with that what we
saw in new jersey
people calling 800 gambler helpline the
number of people with sports betting
related problems ballooned from four
percent annually up to about 16 percent
annually four-fold increase so we're
starting to see more people starting to
exhibit gambling related harms we're
also pushing it out to the younger
demographic our college students
you know people in high school who
shouldn't even be gambling yet are
partnering with their older siblings or
parents and placing bets on sporting
contests works we're normalizing the
expansion of gambling amongst our youth
i anticipate we're going to see those
numbers grow as time goes on that's why
we have to get into the schools at an
early age prevention is all about
starting soon you know schools allocate
funding for prevention for drug and
alcohol but when you talk about gambling
it's just not a problem that they see
because you can't see a gambling problem
that well yet we know people walk around
struggling with gambling addiction and
it's the loved ones who also suffer
because gambling has some of the largest
financial consequences of the of the
major addictions as well as some of the
highest suicidal ideation and attempt
yeah it's a it's an interesting
addiction
i'm thankful i never um
i think about the suicide piece
that's something that never crossed my
mind and i've lost friends since
september 11th when i lost a lot of
friends i lost uh two more to suicide
after september 11th they couldn't deal
with life and then along my journey of
recovery in the last 12 years
uh i've lost friends of suicide from
gambling addiction because they just
that they can't they just can't take it
anymore and i remember one in particular
was on
i was at a meeting in north jersey some
number of years ago on july 3rd the
night before independence day
and i remember this young man was a wall
street executive like myself uh in
recovery was struggling was still living
at home couldn't move out because he had
no money left
and he grew up in a family where they
gambled every friday night so he's at a
ga meeting trying to get well
and he would go home to an environment
where they were playing poker and it was
a family where it was the father the
uncle the siblings and every time he'd
come in they'd say come on sit down
you're playing and they'd force him at
the table
he couldn't take it anymore he ended up
taking his own life on july 4th
and i remember him talking about giving
his therapy that night talking about
freedom from addiction and independence
and he says i think there's only one way
i can get free of this thing and i just
remember that
none of us knew at the time that he was
talking about
completing
suicide
but
looking backwards
that's probably what he was referring to
that was hard
dan what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned from all
of this
i'm thankful
i think um
coming out of september 11th having
opportunities in my life from baseball
to working in the city to
meeting just amazing people every day
and hearing what people can accomplish
with what little they have at times
i think i'm just thankful
i think we need to really work on
listening more than we speak that's
something i
i'm here talking with you today but it's
something i really try to do
because people just want a voice they
want to be heard and they they want to
have an outlet and that's something that
i realized that i don't think i had
so i try to give that i try to i try to
give more compassion versus comparison
that's a big thing that i focus on today
when we talk about social media and the
age of technology we see so many people
falling for that comparison model you
know i'm not good enough i'm not smart
enough i'm not pretty enough i'm not as
good as blank right comparing yourself
to someone else
letting people know that that you are
worthy
you you do deserve to be here you are
right where you're supposed to be in
this moment and just trying to work with
people to help give them hope and
encouragement
you know one of the things i realized i
was very thankful that i was reconnected
with my higher power spending time back
in the church something my grandparents
instilled in me at an early age but i
always revolted against it
was confusing to me i didn't want to be
a part of religion i didn't want
anything to do with religion but what i
realized over time and one of my biggest
takeaways is that it's not religion it's
a relationship
and in recovery from addiction we need
to form
relationships
because when we're in active addiction
we want isolation relationship is the
furthest thing from our mind when we're
an act of addiction because of the shame
and stigma
so today as i go around the country and
as i work in the field that i do and i'm
very blessed and thankful for that
i've helped people focus on relationship
help people realize that they are good
enough and they're worthy enough and
that it's okay to not be okay and just
always have a trusted friend by their
side
excellent dan what a great talk thank
you so much you're welcome thank you i'm
glad you're doing better thank you thank
you
you